you've mentioned elsewhere in terms of
video games elder scrolls yeah did you
play that yeah of course it's probably
my favorite game if i could live in a
world you played morrowind and skyrim i
played
oblivion oblivion i played a little bit
of morrowind but i didn't like the
graphics back then but i really played
the can i swear on this podcast yeah i
played the [ __ ] out of um oblivion and
skyrim like
eight characters played it all the way
through i have to do all the quests that
type of thing what's your favorite thing
about those games
um why did you spend so much time in
that world because i i like games that
you can grind
what do you mean by grind so like
stardew valley for instance right
there's a lot of to the farm that's
farming right okay it's the same thing
as skyrim the reason why i like it is
that there's a lot of like
i have to collect a lot of these things
you know i mean i have to just
constantly pick things up you know i
mean yeah like for instance in skyrim
there's a mushroom called blister wart
mushroom that you can pick and then you
can make it into some sort of formula
right yeah yeah ocean yeah right yep so
i would spend like
literally human 12 hour days just going
to every cave and picking up as much
blister wart as i could like that kind
of grinding
you know what i mean yeah yeah so you're
actually the randomly generated quests
that gives you
design for people like you yeah you
don't get bored that's the that's the
fun yes that's the fun for me okay yeah
there's always something to do and i
find
like when when you play a game that's
linear like
there's certain games where you have to
go this way right i don't like games
like that yeah i like open world games
where i can make choices and i can grind
if i want yeah yeah would you stay in
that world if you could live in that
world in the in the elder scrolls world
that's how i feel
in reality or become like a animated
thing in there oh no say like virtual
reality we're moving towards that
direction oh yeah if you look at skyrim
you mentioned graphics it's become
it's starting to get realistic yeah like
i i i'll sometimes just walk around i
mean it's been a while but i'll just
walk around in skyrim yeah you can uh
there's code you can turn off enemies
and you just walk around really you can
just listen to music and just walk
around
that's what you did yeah yeah yeah yeah
i would do that wouldn't you do that
would you do it with me
you sure we would have a house together
oh i mean live i thought walk around no
no no no if you and i were able to go
into skyrim yep right and walk around
and live together would we make love no
no no man don't go there okay no no no
because we like girls man
that's right it's not gay well you told
me it's not gay yeah yeah yeah all right
so you and i would yeah i would hunt you
would gather
but in that world there's no hunting
yeah there is hunting i would do have
the because we don't have to find
bandits we have to fight i'm not gonna
gather a bandit i'm gonna hunt them but
i think it's all about the potion you
don't need the bandits okay well we
could do this we could you could be the
guy that like defends our place yeah
right i'll gather all the um blister
award all the white caps all the
mushrooms i'll i'll get all the food
yeah i mean i'll go to white run
remember white run yep right or winter
hold and i'll do all the like quests
that have nothing to do with you know i
mean so no dragons though no no dragons
but we would have a banquet we'd invite
the dark dark brotherhood yeah right the
fighters guild we definitely invite them
mages guilds we'd invite them are you a
thief kind of guy i'm a thief guy yeah
i'm a bit i'm for life yeah i'm a thief
guy for life and you still wouldn't
invite andrew schultz to that no no no
but what a piece of [ __ ] though huh
because let me just say something okay i
just want to get back to that okay sure
so i met him
at the montreal comedy festival and him
and i
are kindred
souls we really connected yeah
and he did my podcast he's done it
several times done his we've we've like
communicated on the phone this and that
and to me and then he invites whitney
cummings which whitney is a good friend
of mine but what i'm saying is is that i
know
andrew as well as whitney knows them i
don't think that whitney knows them more
than i do
right what if it was a competition like
it was a tie
you know and like nba like a bobby lee
versus whitney yeah what
in what way do you think she's better in
what way do you think you're better
i think it's all about gender optics
okay right so he's a comedian
he has all these alpha males coming and
he's like all right i can i have one
more seat left yeah whitney or bobby but
bobby's although i don't think there was
a lot of koreans there so he could have
used that card this is true right but i
think he went for you know whitney's a
woman it's better for optics okay so she
was a diversity hire for the wedding
yeah
i see it was it was pretty fun it was
pretty i have to say i don't it was joe
rogan yeah i know
his wife i get it yeah and then uh
whitney are those the only comedians
that were there
i spent the whole time talking to jose i
i think no i don't think there was that
many comedians so i'm kind of joking
about
it was a pretty pretty small wedding
yeah
you